yeah quite a significant development
um what we know is that at least two
salvos of rockets were fired out of
Southern Lebanon into the Galilee region
in Northern Israel and Air Raid Sirens
was sounded as a result we believe this
was dozens of missiles the exact number
not yet known some of those were
intercepted by Israel's Iron Dome
missile defense system some though did
land causing damage there's been reports
of a couple of injuries although those
reports say that the injuries are pretty
minor from what we're hearing so far at
least now there have been reports that
these readys have already started
responding using artillery fire and
there's a heavy presence of Israeli Jets
up on the northern border but we're yet
to get more detail on that so why might
this have happened why might this new
front be opening up well almost
certainly it has got something to do
with what has been happening the Alex
are compound over the last couple of
days when Israeli forces have gone in to
remove Palestinian worshipers and that's
caused uproar around the Muslim world I
think there is potentially another
factor in it and that is that Israel has
been carrying out a series of airstrikes
against targets over the border and
neighboring Syria in recent days and of
course you do have a commonality between
the various groups there who's behind it
well maybe Palestinian factions in
southern Lebanon but they will not have
acted without at least the knowledge if
not even the tacit approval of Hezbollah
who control Southern Lebanon and it does
raise the Specter of a potential very
dangerous new front in this if Hezbollah
and Israel do come to blows and it
escalates further